this isn't your home what are you
talking about this is the umbrella
academy
the umbrella academy is back but the new
world they're facing
offers a whole new set of challenges
namely the discovery of the sparrows
season two left us with so many
questions
why is ben alive now why is he a sparrow
who exactly are the sparrows what we
want to know is how this new team of
superheroes is going to rock the world
of the umbrella academy
since it isn't really their world
anymore yeah you're right i'm just happy
that we're home
loyalty and betrayal have always been
major themes in this series so how will
the introduction of the new characters
especially the new ben affect the
umbrella academy we've grown to know and
love
this is the sparrow academy
if we didn't think it was a full house
with the umbrella academy before
the addition of the sparrows definitely
makes things pretty crowded
season 2 left us wondering what would
become of the umbrella academy
since in the world they've returned to
the mansion is no longer their home
not only that but the world they exist
in is the sparrow world
it seems like the introduction of these
new superheroes will lessen the control
that the umbrella academy superheroes
have
naturally the umbrella academy will be
thrown by the new kids in town
especially since one of them used to be
one of their own it will be interesting
to see how the dynamics of the umbrella
academy shift as
for each of them there is a sparrow many
of whom have similar qualities of
character
the fact is this offers plenty of
opportunity for clashing and camaraderie
between the two groups
what the hell did we do now the umbrella
crew will need to find their way back to
their own world and the additions of the
sparrows could make that trickier
the umbrella siblings have never faced a
group that was just like them
and at this point they don't know how
powerful they
are on top of all that they have the
added stress of seeing their former
brother with a new family to whom he's
loyal
a major question to contemplate is what
will happen to ben
if the umbrella academy manages to find
their way back to their own reality
is it possible for ben to be part of
that
it may be possible that he exists in
both worlds
can ben choose which world he's part of
now that he's alive and in one reality
the televator could definitely come in
handy for that
we saw the plans for it in season two
and with it could come a solution to the
issue of the sparrows since it will
allow a person to travel through space
and time
it seems like that would be the easiest
way to get back to their own world
you're so independent go fight your own
battles
ben is back season two left us with a
surprising reintroduction of the
original member of the umbrella academy
touting a new look character and
personality the machiavellian tactician
is far from the ban we knew so how will
this affect the og umbrella academy
well it's important to note that he's
higher in the sparrow hierarchy than he
was with the umbrella crew
moving up four places to number two as a
sparrow even though his proper rank is
number two
it's obvious he's ready to be leader of
the pack since he's a higher rank in
this world
chances are he won't want to team up
with his umbrella siblings
however if he did what would that mean
for the sparrows
the fact that ben has been reintroduced
as a sparrow means he can potentially
shift the dynamics for both sets of
siblings
and be number one regardless of which
family he's with
with this new sparrow being brought back
fully alive
we're curious about the possibility that
his abilities have changed and
if there are untapped powers to be
introduced
he could have skills beyond his
ex-siblings comprehension and we can't
forget the sentimental factors
the umbrella academy isn't just facing
new strangers
they're facing one of their own further
we already know that ben is a completely
different person now and doesn't
remember his siblings
so this is bound to cause friction
between him and the umbrellas
we're definitely curious to see how emo
ben interacts with his former siblings
either way there is definitely a chance
for the relationships between the og
crew
to grow stronger or completely fall
apart
and then there was the cycronium cube
character
aka christopher aka sparrow
number seven this unusual sparrow
sibling is bound to switch things up in
the series
while we know he is considered a mentor
and mediator for his siblings
we don't know where christopher the cube
came from meaning he could throw the
umbrellas a lot of challenges
on their journey getting back to their
world how exactly does this cube fit in
with the sparrows
well there is a possibility the cube is
actually harlan
while his name is christopher what if
this is what harlan is like in an
alternate universe
ben exists here in a totally different
way so why not
what about the chance that the cube
contains a soul and that soul used to be
a living human sibling named christopher
since we don't know his origins we don't
know for sure that he has always been a
cube
then there is also the idea that maybe
sparrow number seven
is actually an ai caregiver for the
sparrow's siblings
he is viewed as their protector after
all we're
really curious to discover the depth and
powers of our new cycronian pal
especially since we already know he is
quite powerful
in fact it gives him a huge advantage
over the umbrella academy crew since he
can use his powers to weaken
all of them at once if they're together
the addition of the sparrows themselves
adds a major twist for the umbrella
academy but the fact is
there's still so much that's unknown
presenting us with obstacles and
possibilities beyond the abilities of
the umbrella siblings
april 2nd 2019 the day after the
apocalypse
we've got a full year to think about it
since the new season won't be released
until sometime in 2022
so let us know what you think in the
comments if you enjoyed be sure to hit
that like button and make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss a thing
from the things